[Music]
yeah in twenty years of distinguished
lectures of the MIT lab for computer
science I think this is the largest
crowd we've had congratulations bill as
all of you know we're celebrating the
20th year of the distinguished lectures
of the MIT lab for computer science and
our policy is never to invite a speaker
again but since this is the 20th year we
broke the policy and Bill is coming here
for the second time and I think that is
very appropriate those of you who know
about the series know that we like to
introduce our speakers with a little
tidbit from their personal lives that
may not be known since there are so many
young people in the audience and after
all these distinguished people are great
role models bill as you all know grew up
in Seattle went to school there then
went to Harvard and I think everybody
knows what happened from that point on
so let's not talk about that instead
let's talk about two things I'll keep
this very short what turned him into
science technology software what were
the earliest forces because I know many
of you have been through the same kind
of experiences well bill says that until
the seventh grade he was getting lousy
grades in math and then a great math
teacher came and said to him I have
confidence in you you can do much better
then the teacher roped him in to do math
puzzles
then after he got excited with math
puzzles the teacher got him to do them
faster and one thing led to the other
and the fire was ignited the other big
thing that I asked all our distinguished
lectures to do for the young people in
the audience is to summarize their
entire life's experience into one or two
sentences giving the young people a
charge a mission for what to do in their
careers here is Bill Gates mission to
you
he said I don't know how it all happened
I love to play with software it's a
fascinating thing I said Bill give me a
sentence or two he said find something
you really like to do and about which
you have a great deal of curiosity and
it may be very surprising to you and to
the world even if it doesn't look like
it might work at first it might work
after all
Bill Gates
well good afternoon what I'm gonna go
through today is talk a little bit about
now the world of computing has derived
on the communication scene and I'm gonna
have a pretty broad impact because of
that and talk about some of the research
areas that suggest for software that are
very exciting and at the same time very
difficult and then I'll leave as much
time as I can for questions at the end
well as was said I got into this thing
by dropping out of school and I'm not
recommending that but if the thing
you're passionate about you think wait
there's only a critical time window to
get involved in sometimes it it does
work and for me that was the kid
computer on the cover of popular
electronics in January 1975 my friend
Paul and I had been working in software
and we thought boy we want to be there
early on and try and contribute some
software and that was based on Paul's
educating me about Moore's law that
these machines would become immensely
powerful more powerful than even the
most expensive computers of the day and
so we we started off on that course
really believing that software was quite
distinct from hardware and that if you
wanted to have a company doing state of
the art software it ought to be very
neutral to the various hardware
providers and really optimize hiring and
training around the software because it
is quite different and PC has come a
long ways in the little bit over 20
years since then not only the power as
Moore's law has has done its work but
also the the overall experience the the
use of graphics the communications in
and out of the machine it's easy to look
at the machines we have today and say
boy you know how did we ever use the
machines of four or five years ago but
certainly four or five years from now
we'll be seeing the same thing
we'll be saying you know why didn't we
have a better user interface why didn't
we have motion video 3d graphics
built-in I think it's not being too
presumptuous now to say that the PC is
as it's connected to the Internet is
will be as important as any major
advance and communications people talk
about this being the Information Age
well what the heck does it mean
information age very strange term well
what it means is that in the same way we
take electricity or running water we
take that completely for granted now
it's part of our regular experience
we'll take for granted the idea of using
a variety of information appliances
connected up to the Internet as our way
of getting information abstain up to
date of transacting business of finding
people with with common interests and
unlike those previous advances however
this one in the period of a decade will
become pervasive people have a tendency
to overestimate what can happen in two
years and underestimate what can happen
in in 10 years and certainly with the
internet I think we're seeing a lot of
that right now
people who debunk it and say it will
never be mainstream there they're just
wrong at least we're betting in a big
way that they're wrong but people who
think all these problems and in
acceptance will come in two or three or
four years time I think they're under
estimating that it does take times for
these things to be adopted even today
you know when I go to read the newspaper
yeah I go up and and I look at the Wall
Street Journal online and I look at the
trade magazines online but I always find
myself picking up the real Wall Street
Journal and scanning it now it partly
has to do with the resolution of
computer screens it partly has to do
with familiarity but I don't I know very
few people who moved all together to
rely on on the Internet for all the
information they get
so it will take some time and yet if you
compare it to these previous advances
it's far more rapid than any one of
those in fact these advances took place
over at least one generation so somebody
who was around and in working when the
invention came through didn't really
have to care about it it was only people
who were growing up the next generation
who had to think how to how to make it
part of their everyday activity now as
this is all happening of course the
machines and I used the term PC very
broadly will be improving quite
dramatically a larger storage is
important so that we can start to do
caching at many levels so all those
pages that you like to go out and see on
a regular basis they're just going to be
there the faster processor is is
important to create a 3d virtual
environment to do the kind of rec
recognition and inference that you want
to have in these environments
I think voice input is is absolutely
necessary to get into the mainstream I
think people underestimate the
importance of screen technology and it's
wonderful to see there are literally
dozens of approaches for getting low
cost much higher dots per inch type
screens available at very broadly
eventually I think we'll talk about
computer devices primarily just by
seeing what the size and the resolution
of the screen is all the way from the
pocket-sized device to the desktop
device to the wall size device to the
stadium device that will be the one
unique distinguishing characteristic
this internet phenomena is an incredible
thing and although for many many years
we were optimistic about online services
that people would dial up at 1200 baud
and find something cool there it was
disappointing it just never caught on it
never got enough people for it to make
sense to build a community or to invest
in publishing or to think about
advertising as a meaningful thing there
and it certainly was a surprise to me
that in 93 and 90
or a lot of things that have been around
for some time tcp/ip and in some newer
protocols particularly HTTP HTML
actually got electronic communication to
critical mass I started to get a glimpse
of it when one of the people who worked
worked for me went back to his
University Cornell and said that it
wasn't just computer scientists out
there on the web it was everybody in the
university and that was that was 93 by
94 the phenomena was in full force and a
phenomena much more with a lot more
attention being paid to it than any that
I than I have ever seen before when the
PC industry was getting going there were
a lonely group of people a few people
who believed and we'd get together in
these small little industry shows and
say we know and and IBM doesn't know
well leader we had to invite IBM and to
help make it happen but that's a long
story
it was it it was a group of pioneers
working on their own with this
revolution in electronic communications
it's so mainstream you can't get away
from it even if you wanted to you can't
turn on your TV set without seeing lots
and lots of URLs you can't read
magazines without encountering that and
there's almost a a Gold Rush type
phenomena that we're seen here that's a
fantastic thing because it means the
level of investments are very high the
innovation is is quite rapid and we
actually went out and interviewed
musician down in Bermuda and we talked
to a lot of people but we thought he was
the most articulate about what the state
of the art is and and what's really
going on with the internet phenomena so
let's go ahead and look at a movie of
what this musician he had to say
hahaha it's digital mine it's really
please
if you have a satellite dish on the lawn
and now computer is your best friend you
spend your free time losing the info
from your on the net for hours on end if
you think you understand my fluid and
all the deals that Villa is pursuing if
cyberspace is your kind of place and
you're a technophile at heart your
state-of-the-art oh yeah your
state-of-the-art
[Music]
so necessity mari de cuando futur back
up to me these cookies
provide to internal computer but he can
my lord krishna chest simply traveling
hora c vu toka TV pen serial aguado
dollar swara k comparing a low spot a
televised evil la IBM that weapon
attends immediate writer Matsuura
salon PhD mother teresa castle antipas
or grazie Padre Rasheeda write poetry
Paternoster immediate a mental gratified
yeah proposing to della swara que para
ninos party IBM atresia Mille grazie
Padre her may your previous collie spot
in quicken / Eva in mythical Charlie
Charlie
[Music]
the latest in technology and anti
athlean connection you've got your names
without a biology and have a digital
obsession if you be in the best home
pages a really cool cuz they are right
if you like to have another guys unit
back and you think that makes you smart
you're state-of-the-art
[Music]
have you ever worn a fax machine on your
head you will and the company that will
make money every time can you convert
your state of they are with the web of
wealth system you can start today with
an online service then run an
interactive television system from the
comfort of your own living room
you'll learn how to make deals to lunch
and take 15% of the gross
so get John a vs. amazing web of wealth
system by calling this toll-free number
today
Thank You friends before I discovered my
web of wealth system I was working two
menial jobs I couldn't even afford to
buy my wife a used car but today I'm on
wife number four and they all drive
fabulous cars just like this by
realizing that venture capitalist have
to turn ordinary people like you and me
into millionaires or they don't get rich
either plus just mention the Internet in
your business plan and they won't care
if you're on parole
you'll be funded I guarantee it why
because as this chart proves soon
there'll be more internet than people
folks nobody understands the internet
but everyone's afraid of being left out
with my web of wealth you can be a part
of this explosive growth yeah I'd really
like to be on that superhighway to fame
and riches so did you sign me up today
to the web of wealth my point to you is
that everyone has some worthless content
languishing around in their garage some
weird little fetish tucked away in some
closet please put it on the net and you
too in days we'll be a global sensation
folks everyone is cruising the net from
busy executives eager to expand their
mind to people with so much time on
their hands they just don't know what to
do
it's how they stay informed about what's
hot what's not folks let's hear from
some of the thousands of people who have
used my web of wealth system I started
my first software company with a high
school buddy it turned out okay
but since then I've discovered the web
of wealth and Hollywood's beat a path to
my door thank you John avarice believe
me it's so easy to get into the online
service business if I can do it so can
you
order John a versus web of wealth system
today and get into the digital age
operators are standing by now you'll be
banking
we'll be ordering pizza and you'll be
sending mail with a $12,000 computer
instead of 32 cent stamps before we
discovered the web of wealth system my
friends and I were just struggling
filmmakers but now we've got our very
own media company and thanks to the web
of wealth we're no mickey mouse
operation
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we've got all this
excitement the biggest rolled gold rush
of all time taking place what what's
going to hold it back well as I say
there's social adoption getting used to
using this to gather information and buy
things but we also have a technology
barrier there's one element in this
picture that doesn't proceed it sort of
Moore's law type Ric type rates and
that's the local loop connecting up
primarily homes but also businesses and
here we can look at sort of three
generations of capability we have
today's Potts phone next network where
we can use 2088 modems and dial-up and
of course text is very fast in pictures
are just barely okay it takes anywhere
from two to ten seconds to get a webpage
down that has fairly high resolution
images now across pots people think they
might be able to squeeze out another
factor of two particularly if they go
asymmetric in the use of it but that's
going to be about it
and yet for quite some time that'll be
how a high percentage of households are
connected up originally there was a view
well five years ago there was a view
that the companies would skip over any
sort of mid band approaches and go right
to broadband in fact there was a view
that they'd skip over the PC and they
connect up TVs for video on-demand in
cable and phone companies we're trying
to outdo each other with big promises of
how many millions of people they would
have hooked up by now well if you go out
there and look at how many people are
hooked up it's a few thousand it's a
number that rounds to zero and so
something happened
well as they were making those promises
they weren't really thinking about what
the revenue opportunity was people saw
that that simply by doing digital
compression in using broadcast digital
broadcast your take rate on pay-per-view
where you only do say the top 10 or 20
movies you get 75 percent of the revenue
of a true video on-demand system so your
extra money to fund from that
application to fund a true ATM fiber
network is very modest indeed and new
applications whether for medical or
travel there was no way to bootstrap
them that is without the users there
weren't the applications without the
applications there weren't the users
time warner made a valiant effort with
their orlando trial putting twenty
thousand dollar machines into people's
homes to just try it out but it didn't
spark into something important now
throughout all this clearly the PC was
getting stronger I'm particularly in
terms of the home market and then the
internet came along and and woke
everybody up to the fact that there's an
evolutionary path that is we can keep
increasing the bandwidth get better
audio support get better video support
and move to have higher and higher
bandwidths that eventually will reach
every home now some of those
intermediate steps are grouped under
what I call mid band here is DN PC cable
modems ADSL any of these approaches let
the still images come in incredibly good
speeds and let you start playing with
video none of them are good enough that
you'd sit and watch a two-hour movie
through a mid band connection so that
awaits sort of the ultimate Holy Grail
which is the broadband and broadband
will happen we were spending a lot of
time developing software for interactive
TV and a lot of the work we're now
applying to the internet insecurity a
lot of the new user interface work we
have comes out of that interactive TV
work in fact the idea of being able to
partition media servers so you can
deliver audio and video
using low-cost technology you don't have
to have a essentially a supercomputer
server to do that that all comes out of
that interactive TV working is directly
applicable to the internet so now the
world at large I think has a more
realistic view of how bandwidth rolls
out and to be honest I think there's a
lot of households that as long as it's
narrowband it's just not fast enough or
compelling enough the information they
need they can get from the newspaper or
calling someone up and it's only when we
get into the realm of rich interaction
that it'll start to be as pervasive as
we want it to be now there will be quite
a few physical device types hooked up
the PC and and we'll see more and more
differentiation between desktop and
portable and certainly there will be a
way of using your TV to connect to the
web pages are not authored to work with
that type of display today that's fairly
straightforward we need to define have a
well-defined subset of broad HTML in
particular in terms of what kind of
add-on capabilities what variety of
media objects we're going to support so
that if we have two ROM that software
make it run in a finite amount of RAM
and this can work
so set-top boxes building the
electronics and the TV or using game
machines which are out there and you can
plug in a modem and a browser those
would be how the TV gets pulled in
certainly a voice handset makes sense
connected up it's a great trade-off in
terms of the the size of the device and
simplicity and that's often what you
want and it should be nice to have the
connectivity for voice with the way that
that things are tariff there we also are
big believers in a machine that you
carry around in your pocket that
connects through digital wireless in a
sense these personal digital assistants
things like Newton or the sharp machines
or Scion are sort of progenitors of this
class but I think there's a a radical
change in how you think about it when
you have the digital connectivity when
you can just walk through a hotel lobby
and
out by having the wireless connection
where you can board an airplane without
physical tickets and select a
see-through using that digital
connection when the GPS feature is cheap
enough that your scene maps and it's
populated with all the nearby things
that you might be interested in and
certainly there are many many other
locations will see pcs including in the
automobile there's a lot of industry
competition and it's part of what makes
our industry so much fun there are
multiple companies with operating
systems there are multiple companies
with browsers Microsoft is a distant
distant number-two in that competition
we having just entered it fairly
recently there's a lot of competition
over defining what is openness openness
to me means that anything to me clone
there's no patents there's no
intellectual property that stands in the
way of somebody creating something
that's compatible but better and the
beauty of that is it forces you to keep
prices extremely low and listen to the
customer feedback about how you can do
better versions all the popular products
that Microsoft has ever done DAWs
windows they've been cloned but we've
been able to move fast enough to stay
ahead here we've been on the other side
of the coin in businesses like
spreadsheets and word processing where
we started with very low market share
but the companies involved not only
didn't they have anything proprietary
that they could protect but they didn't
move their application along so whether
it's one two three or WordPerfect their
market share fell over time you know
perhaps NetWare is a similar situation
and if we do extremely well then we'd
add browsers to the list of such
competitions now part of that is that we
have a vision of integration of actually
having the local information we access
on the PCB is easy to get to as remote
information and in fact your things like
help files
well wife
those just be webpages there's no reason
you should have to think about help any
differently from any other text that
comes up on the screen and likewise
directories themselves you should be
able to annotate you can think of
today's directories it's just a
degenerate case of a web page it's a web
page with where each file is essentially
a link which sort of harkens back to the
kind of Gopher approach well we want to
take and let you put arbitrary HTML
including ActiveX controls into those
pages so it's it's easy to find your way
around the there's a major thing that's
always gone on of PCs versus expensive
computers as the chip technology and pcs
has gotten better and better as the
software has gotten richer it's taken
over more and more of the computer
marketplace and it's fair to say that
within the next two or three years that
performance and capabilities will be
such that you can reach up virtually to
the top of the computing hierarchy and
this is greatly reinforced by the
positive feedback phenomena of getting
more app the more applications you get
the more volume you get the more volume
you get the more its attractive it is to
build those applications more recently
some of these these people like well son
in particular have taken attack of not
trying to sell a more expensive computer
but selling something less and we don't
know what it is yet
when they're there actually exists this
is a so-called networked computer we'll
be able to see what the trade-off
involved is if you're talking about a
high quality screen that you're gonna
sit close to and something that runs a
browser it's tough to eliminate much
that's in a PC because a browser is the
most demanding PC application its users
more RAM it grows faster than anything
including word processing and
spreadsheets all the classic things that
tend to push the limits are out the
window it's the browser and browser
growth if you just take Netscape as an
example it's doubling in size every nine
months and you know at some point
there's got to be a limit there in terms
of what can be done but still it's very
relevant additions
that are being put in so it certainly
isn't gonna stop anytime soon they
there's so much software involved in
making the web fulfill this dream of
information at your fingertips there's
there's programming tools but I I'd be
the first to say that most people who
create webpages won't be programming
even if they want to put in little
animations and buttons and rich
interactive behavior they'll just have a
palette of controls and if they say okay
I want my users to vote on this they'll
drag in a voting control and it'll
automatically be connected up to the
right database capability there so the
actual programming tools where job has
now come in it's a first-class language
that's going to be a choice just as much
as C has ever been or COBOL or basic or
any of the other popular languages
that's one dimension here but there's
another dimension of helping people
manage large webs of content when you
get thousands and thousands of links
it's very hard to picture they're all
correct and when you start to reorder
your taxonomy how do you make sure that
links that people are still holding that
they get redirected to the right place
you also have tricky issues of
versioning if I want to prepare do some
work preparing a new website I don't
want to duplicate everything I have
today I just essentially want a version
off of that versioning also comes up in
terms of preservation now one thing
about written material is you know
usually we can go back and dig around
and find a historical record of what a
product brochure looked like or what a
company was offering with the web
there's a tendency now to just
completely wipe out the historical
electronic presence and that certainly
won't do over time we have to have an
approach that allows for archiving so
you can always go back and and see what
was being said at any point in time so
managing this type of content brings in
some new issues if we go back to the
people who are in a sense the conceptual
pioneers of hypertext people
Doug Engelbart at Stanford Research or
Ted Nelson with his Xanadu project they
had a much richer concept of what
hypertext would be all about in terms of
annotation and tracking and even even
commercial mechanisms that might make
sense there than we've been able to
implement to date so lots of work to go
on that has to go on in an integrated
fashion one problem that corporations
have is that administering all this
software we have database software male
software web software a file sharing
software you have all these things have
different interfaces different
administration different security that's
a real mess and so we've got to really
pull it together and take public key
encryption and these these x.509
certificates and make that the
foundation for directory that can be
used across all the different
applications and therefore not only
simplify the cost within a corporate
network but allow these inner enterprise
applications to work because the trust
hierarchies can be set up so that
information moves where it should and
doesn't move where it it shouldn't now
the Internet is today buta sort of an
environment that government's not
involved and it'd be nice if we could
leave it that way but I have to say that
it's I think it's very unlikely that
institutions like the security Exchange
Commission are gonna let people you know
do offerings on the internet without
looking at the honesty of the material
that's being promoted I think it's
unlikely Federal Trade Commission will
let people scam buyers without looking
into that and and laws related to libel
or copyright and those things probably
will I have to be accommodated but it's
a very difficult accommodation because
we haven't really defined modes of
behavior and we haven't dealt with the
fact that this is a global network and
it's going to be a terrible problem if
there's overly restrictive laws that
really prevent people from taking
advantage of but certainly the
telecommunications deregulation bill
went too far in terms of trying to limit
indecency on the internet that is
there's now a court suit that Microsoft
and a bunch of people other people are
involved in in suing the federal
government to get that overturn which
I'm I'm very optimistic about there are
major issues if this thing is as
important as we like to think it is of
making sure it's pervasively available
so sort of duplicating the creation of
the public library system which took a
period of over a hundred years to make
sure anybody could get get two books
that's got to be done and the
investments in communications
infrastructure has to be there and one
of the hot issues right now that I'm
going to go down to Washington DC for
another round of lobbying on is that
this country has restrictive export laws
on encryption technology and today they
only let us export 40-bit encryption
which of course can be broken by many
people in this audience and it won't
doesn't take you more than a day C to do
it it's a pretty ludicrous situation
because it's not as though there's some
US monopoly on understanding encryption
technology and the problem is that
software vendors outside of the US are
now starting to provide packages that
have very good encryption the problem is
that organizations like the National
Security Agency justify their budget on
being able to tap into people and if
mass-market software has very very good
encryption then it just makes their job
dramatically harder most of the work
they're able to do benefits from
sloppiness and by having it built into
these electronic systems you'll get rid
of a lot of that sloppiness and so it's
a tough issue and believe me it's very
hard to lobby against these intelligence
organizations but we'll see what what
can be done there so definitely a lot of
issues that come up I was always very
proud of the fact that you know for the
first ten years of Microsoft
history we didn't have to think about
government and you know lobbying and
anything like that it doesn't seem like
that much fun in some ways but now as a
major company in the industry there are
a broad set of issues you know making
sure immigration laws don't get overly
restrictive that we have to spend time
in and get involved in I want to quickly
talk about some research areas and
you'll see you as I talk about these
that these are areas that there's great
work going on all over the world some of
them are ones that that Microsoft has a
research group with about a hundred and
twenty people nowadays that it works on
some of these and they're all predicated
on computing cost communications cost
declining so that we can almost think of
them as free over time and one of the
things I think that's wonderful about
software is unlike a lot of companies
where research tends get very decoupled
from the mainline company and almost be
partitioned off as though it wasn't part
of the same company in the software
world the ability to take great research
ideas and when they work out being able
to put them in products and take
advantage of them is quite incredible
and we've already even though we when we
started the research group we didn't
expect that we're only three years into
it and we're already seen things like
our word processor ship with work that
the natural language group has done I
want to do a little demo of a fun thing
we put together this is just one person
in research
Dave Carlin who was thinking about
computer dialogues and how boring chat
is and what he could do about that
so he was thinking well maybe this 3d
stuff is great but there's no record and
it's hard for lots of people to to watch
into that and so he actually came up
with a fun idea that we call comic chat
and it draws on a very rich art form so
I'm gonna ask
Craig belington to come up and he's
actually gonna connect up and hopefully
show us a comic chat with some people
across across the nation on the west
coast
great thanks bill you mentioned a few
things earlier things like internet
explorer 3.0 which yesterday went to
beta one you can get
that I heard you on
www.microsoft.com/mechanics off is very
excited about that release bill
mentioned the ActiveX technologies
that's included in Internet Explorer
you'll see things like support for Java
support for scripting languages like
JavaScript and VB script support for
frames animated gifs all that good stuff
that you like in HTML or that you don't
like so much in HTML one of the things
that I'm going to show you is an
application called comic chat which is
actually what we call an active document
so this document when you click on it
could come up in place of whatever
container object you happen to be
working in something like a Microsoft
Word Microsoft Excel or a particular web
browser like Internet Explorer 3.0 I'm
just going to I keep hearing this
hissing noise
I'm just going to introduce a to comic
chat I have a character here named
Armando and that's bill G your name is
right there I've always wanted to do
this and pretend I was Bill G up on the
Internet
a lot of people do that I've heard that
what we have here is kind of a more fun
version of a chat room with a record or
a history of things that go on in that
chat room if we can see all the people
that are in the room here's myself as
bill G there's a mark Emmy and Tapscott
in fact I want to get these people's
attention so I'm gonna go ring mark and
he just saw a little dialog box on his
computer and hopefully we've got his
attention now and I can now that I've
selected mark I can say something like
hi and you see my character waves how
are you and it also points to you can
everybody see this okay why don't we
make it a little bigger
okay hi how are you you notice that as I
typed something like hi it started to
wave but then it said how are you so it
pointed to the person that I selected we
can scroll down a little bit someone
doesn't believe that I'm Bill Gates
right I'm Bill Gates and I'm really Ross
Perot can we talk someone asked me how I
am and I'm being wrung back by Mark
whoever that is so he wanted to get my
attention as well so we can scroll down
are you never mind Elvis was here a
while ago this must be a very popular
chat room say I'm glad to be here this
is cool and you notice that he's
pointing to himself as I say that what
are you up to Bill pleased to meet you
all kinds of chat things going on I'm
glad to be here there's cool pointing at
himself so is it still raining in your
neck of the woods I can say things like
cheer up the Sun is coming out and when
I do that I can put the typical colon
and parentheses the little smiley face
and of course when comic chat sees that
it makes my character smile we just have
to catch up to it there we go we're
smiling while we put the little smiley
face in our bubble there I could say
something like laughing doesn't hurt
either and I can do the acronym of laugh
out loud so put that in there and my
character is laughing hysterically as
you can see just by using the laugh out
loud piece there's all kinds of emotions
that you can draw out though which
aren't automatic if I want to say hang
on let's show some emotions and send
that across I'm gonna actually just make
this a little bigger so you can see my
character over here and I can you notice
that we have this wheel on the bottom
right it's kind of like a color wheel
and that you can bring out ranges of
emotions so someone can be kind of happy
or very happy or very angry
so as I move around it's very easy to
bring out different impressions looks
like he's doing a little dance doesn't
it not only can you talk to these
characters you can do things like normal
things you'd find in a comic book
actually what we're calling a comic chat
so bill likes to take risks every once
in a while so we can say runs with
scissors and instead of saying that I
could think it or I can even make it an
action and what happens there is it
actually puts it at the top of the
screen much like you would see in a
comic book so there would be this
narrative going by in the chat room as
well as I'm describing things I can
highlight everyone so I can say
something to everyone and all the people
show up in the room so we can see
everybody it's easy to right-click on
someone and I can ring them again I can
get information about them with their
profile and that should show up at the
bottom hey Bill what's up this man was
raised by armadillos at a roadside park
in Texas he knows lots of armadillo
songs want to hear one we'll skip that
so other things that you can take
advantage of
besides the emotions being the fact that
you can save any of these you can print
these out and it looks like a comic book
this will work with any normal RC server
so I can go up to the Internet and the
people who don't have this client well
I'll actually see them as characters and
if they type something like the smiley
face their character will be smiling and
people who don't have this client will
see well my text completely normally so
it'll work with anyone else who's using
something like this just to shock them a
little bit we do have the option of
changing our character so let's spruce
bill's character up a little bit anybody
have any choices Anna perhaps I'm not
exactly sure what Connor is
we'll have to look into that some aliens
out there and again you can experiment
with their different emotions in the
different settings so something a little
fun something that came out of the
research group again you'll see that
shortly both for the web and for MSN
that's coming chat thank you
I think it illustrates there's a lot of
room for creativity in terms of how
we're gonna do collaborations just
moving on on the topic of where the
frontiers are one of the big ones that
we see is is parallelism it's been kind
of a Holy Grail in computer science for
a long time and as long as you know
process for performance and in memory
subsystems scaled up where most programs
could run on a single computer it wasn't
that important and so you'd have to say
that progress has been been fairly
limited but now that we're looking at
database problems that are absolutely
gigantic deep analysis problems we
clearly need to be a lot stronger in
partitioning distributing problems
across different computers and there are
huge commercial payback for being able
to take sort of arbitrary SQL and see
what the patterns of usage are and being
able to design a system that sets up the
date of the right way testing is another
area where I have to say I'm a little
bit disappointed in the lack of progress
if you think at Microsoft in a typical
development group there's about sixty
percent as many testers as there are
engineers writing code and yet the
engineer spends well over a third of his
time doing testing type work you could
say that we spend more time testing than
we do writing the code and if you go
back through the history of large-scale
systems that's the way they've been but
you know what kind of new techniques are
there in terms of analyzing where those
things come from and having constructs
that do automatic testing very very
little so if you know a researcher out
there and wants to work on that problem
boy we'd love love to put a group
together certainly Security's a tough
problem you've probably all been reading
about two companies in Japan that just
lost over a hundred million dollars
because the pachinko electronic cards
the encryption on the
was cracked and so somebody actually fed
in to the marketplace before they
noticed this is pretty impressive a
hundred million dollars worth of
pachinko little credit slips and just
shows you how much pachinko gets played
in Japan but the idea of having good
security and yet being able to change
those systems that they're broken and
having the amount of damage that can be
done during a period where say you're
your private key has been accidentally
released that's a very tough problem I'm
very much a big believer in structure
unification today we have all sorts of
storage systems we've got files we've
got pages we've got documents we've got
records we've got messages all of those
are stored in different ways and I
really believe that there's some sort of
super file system that has the
replication security rich properties
indexing that can actually unify a lot
of those together and certainly that the
experience of using a computer would be
dramatically better as a result of that
some of the great frontiers have to do
with sensory things generating real
video type images the most advanced
graphics work being able to do more and
more of that in real time there's a
reaaargh attacking of the graphics
subsystem so you don't have the memory
bandwidth bond-like that the frame
buffer is creating that we we've been
very involved in investing in and all
sorts of high-level tools for synthesis
one of the companies that is now part of
Microsoft is Softimage whose software is
used to create things like the dinosaurs
in Jurassic Park
and we want to take those tools and make
them so they can be used by high school
teachers and put neat things together
certainly video recognition is a great
thing as long as you're gonna have a
video conferencing camera why don't you
recognize when somebody sits down why
don't you recognize when they want to
scroll more of a document to read more
if they want to throw the document away
or whatever other crazy gestures they
want to make the computer ought to use
all those spare cycles to sit there and
recognize that now certainly speech is
the Holy Grail 20 years ago people are
optimistic today they're optimistic I
saw a wonderful demo of the work that
Victor zoo's group has done recently and
you know I think certainly over the next
five to ten years those things will be
deployed and used in a powerful way
text to speech we've actually made a lot
of progress recently where we can
actually take a speaker and listen to
them and then do speech synthesis that
we will really sound like the speaker
I'm you know it's amazing how bad speech
synthesis has been but it looks like
just in the next year's that will
improve and certainly linguistics being
able to parse documents and gather
knowledge from documents is one that
that's very important I think software
will also get involved in deep analysis
deep modeling analysis whether it's
using Bayesian inference or some other
type of engine underneath as you browse
the web you think you go to it and you
think well what should I do this weekend
well how can the computer help you with
that you shouldn't have to type in a
bunch of URLs to go do that it should
synthesize for you that information
based on senior past behavior well
that's a fairly deep set of analysis
that that we're just at the beginning of
and likewise bind something learning
about something modeling what you
understand what you don't in rich
collaboration require actually
techniques that are our deep deep AI
problems in terms of really rich
learning I was saying to a smaller group
here meeting with earlier I'm I'm
surprised how little progress there's
been in the last 20 years maybe it's
just because I'm I'm over optimistic but
when I left working in computer science
I thought the thing I was gonna miss was
that within the next decade computers
would start to be able to learn in a
meaningful sense not just have a pattern
that's pre-programmed in that they can
happen to match against but really a
general-purpose
learning eventually if we don't figure
this out will sequence enough
and figure out how the brain does it so
we won't have to figure it out we'll
just use evolution solution I think
we've got maybe 20 or 30 years before
the that approach overtakes somebody
who's trying to do it de novo so this
whole software area is was said in the
introduction I kind of got into it
through serendipity it's a fun area to
work in it's a fast-moving area and by
surprise it's actually a great business
looking ahead there's a lot more room
for breakthroughs and a lot of great
value in in doing these kind of products
well thank you
no pun okay let's turn on the lights
we'll have five minutes of questions
please there are microphones I don't
think we'll be able to take more than
about four people so if you'd like to
ask a question come to one of the mics I
think there's only one mic which makes
it easy hi I have a question
today there's a great push in our school
systems for especially the lower grades
to push kids into learning today's
latest technology and mastering the
today's current computers of software
and stuff just wondering based on web
something that I've heard you say in the
past and read about is this a mistake
that we're not focusing on the basics of
learning versus today's technology and
making good technicians of what is
popular today and welcome to Boston well
there's no need for kids to learn the
specifics of technology I mean the
computer is just a tool and you know I
don't think understanding that is very
valuable because if there's anything
that's going to change rapidly it's it's
the way that those systems are put
together you know I I think learning a
programming language at some point is
valuable because it gives you a sense of
what the computer can do and what the
computer can't do but I certainly don't
see that as as being necessary as part
of a high school curriculum you know the
biggest issue nowadays is just getting
enough computers out there so that
people can individually pursue what
they're curious about following all the
great material that's out there on the
Internet and it's it's more of a
resource problem than a pedagogical
problem I think okay why don't you
identify yourselves as you before you
ask the question please
Alden Hayashi with data mason magazine
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about a research that you're doing
specifically at Microsoft's labs in some
of the areas that you talked about in
your presentation well there's a broad
range of things going on in the graphics
area if you go to SIGGRAPH you'll see
some of the things where we're playing
around with there some fun fun progress
that's a great area we published a lot
of papers about what we're doing in in
natural language a few of the groups are
more obscure there's a group headed by
Charles Simoni that's looking at
programming languages and can we express
our intentions in a higher-level form
it's been an area a lot of people work
on and not made much progress he calls
it intentional programming and it's fun
to have you know risky things like that
Charles wouldn't like it if I
characterized it that way but I that's
certainly how I do it there's about nine
different groups right now in the in the
research group if you had to pick one
the top one which one would you pick as
your most promising well voice in
linguistics is is the most central it's
just so natural if you can choose that
that word and the progress is is quite
good I mean partly by brute force we're
just getting more MIPS to be able to do
these things we're understanding sort of
black boarding where you take context at
different levels and bring that that
together you can't solve the problem
just by thinking of it as a low-level
problem you really have to have high
level knowledge or context in order to
do it well all right professor Patrick
Wong from Northeastern University
computer science I have a question why
internet is doing a lot of good things
to us we are also seeing a lot of are
not ominous signs for instance too many
children and students are playing
internet too many hours without eating
sleeping
and too much crimes such as illegal
cashing out from banking Paul no
information and so forth so what do you
think we should do to avoid disaster
before it is too late before it's out of
control
well I think kids should eat
[Applause]
eight seriously I haven't heard that I
know you know Raman Huijin got into his
math enough he didn't eat much but
remember the average American kid
watches TV thirty hours a week so you
know what if we cut that into doubt a
little bit what have we cut into the
time that they play video games a little
bit now we don't want to cut into the
time they spend reading or playing with
other people are sleeping and eating and
so parents may have a role to play here
and in terms of crime on the internet
the internet will be no more lawless or
less lawless I guess I should say lawful
then any other domain is and so you know
the people who are criminals in real
life will be criminals on the internet
it it it requires the police to get a
little more sophisticated but I don't
see any you know as the internet moves
to the mainstream all those things will
show up it's just part of the maturation
of the of the medium except that the
transporter flows will cause governments
to worry about each other how do you
handle that it that is a very tricky
problem because if you took a least
common denominator approach you know
what does Saudi Arabia want to sense or
what does Singapore want a censor you'd
be down to almost nothing and censorship
is going to be very tough in this world
we're working with w3c which is is
hitting an initiative to have reading
so-called pic system where you have
either self reading a third-party rating
of pictures with the up pages yeah it's
great and that you could have a pantora
parent who says I'm only willing to let
my kids see things that have been rated
if it's unrated and it's outside the
country say I won't let them see it or
more strict might be not letting them
see things inside the country but there
are some very tough problems that have
yet to be worked through about what
kind of laws apply and how do how do
things work all right please my name is
Tim McNerney I'm from Harlequin
incorporated I don't speak for my
employer competition is good for
innovation and market share is a big
concern at people who are looking at
Microsoft have you guys stopped to
consider that you guys could have a very
large effect on creating competition in
the marketplace by some sort of action
on your part you spoke about openness
earlier but there are other people who
are concerned that your operating
systems and your standards de facto
standards are cutting competition off
give something to say about that
[Applause]
there's a couple of things first of all
there there is lots of competition I
mean you know Scott McNealy and IBM and
you know HP there are several dozen
people would come up here and tell you
about the great things they're doing in
operating systems another key thing to
remember is that when we sell someone an
operating system they own it and they
can use it do whatever they want with it
forever the only way that anybody that
we get any additional income at all is
come up with a better version of that
operating system that they might want to
purchase and so we're in some sense our
own biggest competitor the installed
base of things that are out there if
it's not a super improvement if it's not
super inexpensive then nobody's gonna
buy the new operating system they're
just going to continue to work with what
they have and particularly as pcs are
getting to saturation levels where every
desktop worker has a PC the replacement
market is the biggest thing going on
there
you also have what I'll call a
middleware phenomena where you know is
Netscape and an operating system
competitor absolutely even though what
they sell today is not an operating
system it is growing to be an operating
system and so the only question is do we
do a good job taking Internet features
and put those into Windows
so it's integrated while they're
building an operating system around
their browser and there's plenty of room
for both companies to be very very
successful this is to close to not ask
this question will the browser and the
windows and all the good stuff merge and
yeah it's just one thing it's a feature
of the operating system that's my
opinion and that'll be played out in the
marketplace whether that's that's right
or wrong all right thank you just just
to build on that that exact same
question you a sort of a business
strategy question if you look at
Microsoft's at netscape's home pages
from time to time it appears there's a
bit of a pissing contest going back and
forth and he said oh my name is Bill
Habib I'm an alum from class of 1980 so
on
a software company here in Cambridge so
I'm wondering if you could elaborate on
where you which space you think
Microsoft needs to sort of dominate in
the Internet in order to succeed as a
browser desktop is a server as it
commerce which arity you do you think
Microsoft really needs to dominate in in
terms of where the future will go and
where do you think that'll leave
Netscape well in a sense nobody in the
other of the PC rules or internet rules
anything is cloneable anything is
cloneable and so if any of the
marketplace it buyers think that you're
dominating any space then somebody will
come in and clone it offer it at lower
price or offer it with better features
and so there's nothing that stops people
come coming in and those are the name
and you know that's why the PC industry
has been so successful is that people
have been able to clone what iBM has
done in every product we've had has been
cloned by many people now we've been
able to do new versions and keep the
prices down enough to stay ahead but it
is a very risky business nobody has any
guaranteed leadership you know take an
example like tcp/ip stacks we decided to
put that in the operating system do we
dominate it well you know anybody can
offer those things it turns out volume
wise yeah people like it to be tested
and built in and when you know we put
ipv6 in there they'll want that to be
nicely integrated in as well so it's an
element of the system well browsers move
that way well it just depends if we
capture in the operating system
everything people want from the browser
then yes to the degree we don't people
either extend using our architecture or
they'll build something up from scratch
and do it that way so you know that it's
not like a manufacturing business where
you own a bunch of factories and so
nobody else can come in and build
factories in this world what's your
factory you just put the bits on the
internet and boom you can have a hundred
percent market share if you have a
better product yes we'll Clurman second
year at the Sloan School MIT Sloan
School and
organizing team of the MIT 50k
entrepreneurship competition question
for you some of us are going to Netscape
for the summer
what what what advice or message would
you have a stake with us what nets keeps
a good company no I think going there
for the summer would be very exciting
thing the the software you know send me
some email after you're done you know
Jim Jim Clark was our Distinguished
Lecture here just a few weeks ago so no
they're they're doing the work they the
piece of innovation on the Internet is
really fantastic and there are four or
five companies that are part of that and
you know a lot if you get to the content
side there are literally tens of
thousands of companies doing great
things if you mentioned you know some
other companies I might not I might say
they're not on the cutting edge like
Netscape is today how we won't get into
that all right let's go let's go hi I'm
Vincent loop Ian an acoustical engineer
here at MIT and my question is slightly
personal I'm wondering well that person
I speak I heard several times the words
neat and fun and as an engineer I can
certainly relate with that but I also
see some dangers with technocratic
mentalities sometimes which can lead us
to perhaps have to narrow of view on
life and I'm wondering in your own
obviously you've enjoyed a lot of
success but at this point in your career
how can you justify say getting up and
working on neat and fun things every day
as opposed to perhaps you know given the
reality that there are people starving
or you know no but I this is a question
that I've wanted to ask you and like as
I said it is somewhat of a personal
question it's I'm putting you in a hard
spot but social responsibility yes let's
go
[Applause]
well I have a fun job and so I mean it
just makes it worse I you know I get to
work with smart people I get to work on
neat things you know I would change a
thing so that's why I get up and do it
if you know as I get older you know I
Microsoft is still successful then I'll
have resources to give away bill let's
take a point here let's take the
countries of the world that do not have
many resources and you spoke earlier or
something like public libraries is
Microsoft planning or thinking or maybe
it's doing something say for example to
promote the internet ization the
computerization the litter you know
getting into this technology in the
third world in the developing world in
Asia and so on in the US in the u.s. yes
that also works in there thank you well
that there's a number of projects
there's a thing called libraries online
where we take libraries and we fund
staff and equipment and communications
there so that kids can come in and lose
the internet today where I was at the
computer museum because they have an
outreach thing called the computer
Clubhouse where they're going into some
of the poorer neighborhoods in this
community and making computers available
in some of the housing groups and
Microsoft has funded that so there's
things I do personally and there's
things that the company does I do
believe that this technology is very
empowering and that the inequality we
have around the world today will be
lessened you know as all the
universities around the world get hooked
up to this your ability to have the same
access to knowledge will be much better
than it ever was in a physical world
when you can electronically hook up to
all the latest knowledge it's easier to
get to get to an equal footing than it
is when you have to to put together a
library of you know millions of books
and all the kind of in I think in terms
of knowledge I agree with you but in
terms of the information helping those
who already have a rich Market Basket
and resources and not helping the ones
that do not my did not exert a counter
force left to its own devices without
people paying attention might not
information
information technology helped more those
who are rich get richer both his
countries and as individuals and leave
the other ones behind thereby expanding
the gap instead of closing it is
knowledge yeah you could certainly say
that when books first came around they
accentuated the gap between the haves
and have-nots the people who are
literate could read to do a business and
it took a long time between then and
when people said hey let's have
libraries let's have everybody get out
and use those things hopefully this time
there's not nearly that same time leg
between seeing a social imperative for
it to be pervasive I think you're saying
it's gonna be like that maybe all right
I'm a grad student here at MIT I have a
question about internet in the future
and how you see Microsoft in it there's
more information out on the net and
because of Java you're gonna see things
where the information on the net is like
programs and in the future do you see
Microsoft more as an internet provider
of information provider of programs or
organization that collects software and
ideas for and different collecting
content and redistributing it like your
deal with NBC
well they the biggest businesses
worrying is building productivity tools
like Microsoft Office and building and
building the operating system and those
will probably be our biggest businesses
for a long long time to come we're in
the content business so you know we did
we did games starting eighteen years ago
and we were at the e3 show showing off
some of the new things that we've done
and the stuff we've done in a joint
venture with DreamWorks and we are doing
some content things but that won't be
the largest business at Microsoft we
just want to lead the way and show some
examples what can be done but they'll be
that will be a very diversified business
the biggest impact will have will still
be in in defining tools and helping to
contribute to the platform bill as a
distinguished lecturer and past lecturer
of LCS I want to thank you LCS is the
home of the web we welcome the Bill
Gates who
is what Carnegie was to steal
Rockefeller through oil Bill Gates the
software best of luck best wishes
[Applause]